[Musique]
avec une influence euse élise adn c'est
votre vrai nom samedi
c'est mon nom de famille raccourcis donc
c'est pas tout à fait votre vraiment non
c'est un pseudo pour internet
exactement d'accord ok dites moi vous
êtes suivi par combien de personnes
environ trente et un mille personnes
d'accord alors tout le monde veut dire
ouais ça fait beaucoup mais quand on
gratouille un petit peu et qu'on
s'intéresse un peu internet
ce qui est intéressant sur les
influenceurs et des influences je
m'arrêtais si je peux te trompes
c'est le taux d'engagement quel est
votre taux d'engagement je n'en ai je
sais pas de locaux non je ne sais pas je
regarde pas en fait j'interagis
énormément par commentaire alors je
précise pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
le taux d'engagement
c'est le nombre de personnes qui like ou
qui finalement interagissent sur ce que
vous pouvez poster comme photo parce
qu'on peut avoir trois cent mille cinq
cent mille personnes mais très peu
finalement qu'il aie qui a intérêt qui
interagissent parce qu'on peut acheter
aussi des personnes sur internet on pas
se le cacher donc il ya trente et une
personnes qui vous suivent
potentiellement je ne sais pas combien
est votre taux d'engagement mais ce que
je sais c'est qu'on va essayer d'en
savoir beaucoup plus sur les
influenceurs en images maintenant
regarder tu as vu le boss de johnny be
sur les baskets
ah ouais trop envie de les acheter
qu'elles soient hyper fameux comme keira
ferhani qui cumula episol 16,2 millions
d'abonnés sur les réseaux sociaux ou
plus confidentiels les influenceurs les
nouveaux prescripteurs de tendances sur
internet joue un rôle de plus en plus
déterminant pour faire vendre
on en compte près 250 milles à quoi
ressemble-t-il 60% d'entre eux ont entre
19 et 30 ans 40 % à bord des sujets
lifestyle vaste catégorie qui englobe
les sens
si la mode ou la cuisine 72% sont sur
instagram 9% sur youtube 7% sur facebook
et 6% tiennent des blogs
alors peut-on leur faire confiance la
question de leur indépendance vis-à-vis
des marques se posent certaines stars
influenceurs ont des partenariats avec
les marques qui peuvent leur rapporter
des dizaines de milliers d'euros pour
une vidéo
dans la catégorie en dessous un
influenceur doté de 200 mille abonnés
peut-être payé jusqu'à 3000 euros par
poste
mais il faut le reconnaître l'écrasante
majorité des influenceurs 86% ne gagne
pas plus de 5000 euros par an il
bénéficie toutefois de produits gratuits
et d'invitations pour l'aura compris
difficile dans ces conditions de
garantir que derrière la bonne mine de
ces nouveaux leaders d'opinion du web ne
se cache pas un pur commerce des
influenceurs à consommer avec modération
et les adn vous en vivez vous non non
non non la partie des 85 % finalement
d'accord est ce que quelqu'un et sur les
réseaux sociaux la sauver oui oui bien
sûr c'est important pour moi d'être être
visible sur les réseaux est d'être un
petit peu connues en fin de semaine à
double tranchant parce que parfois on
vous ressort des trucs il ya quelques
années c'est ce que je vous souhaite
vous êtes élue miss france le 14
décembre
on peut on peut revenir un petit peu en
arrière on savait que rien ne s'efface y
en a quand même attention méfiance
et vous marie thérèse facebook ouais
c'est tout d'accord mais il ya
différents réseaux vous vous êtes
présente sur instagram essentiellement
j'ai un blog aussi mais instagram et
j'aurais tellement d'accord ok vous
poster des photos comme celle qu'on voit
c'est à dire c'est des photos de mode
exactement comment on fabrique une photo
comme ça alors moi je les fais en
général avec mon conjoint ou à tout seul
avec un trépied quoi donc voilà par
exemple c'était c'était un camaïeu donc
voilà pour à l'entrée dans l'hiver très
bien je vous tiens puisqu'on parle de
mode la mode pour cet hiver qui arrive à
grands pas on l'a compris en bourgogne
franche comté c'est quoi basset c'est ça
c'est des gros pulls et des longues
jupes plissées ou pas donc voilà c'est
on s'emmitoufle effet justement report
de ce nom plus de cette jupe plissée
parce que vous l'avez acheté oui oui
vous avez acheté mais oui parce que on
l'a vu dans le reportage où il vient
souvent des influences sur les
influences euse comme vous se font
offrir des choses par des marques
donc évidemment derrière repose
l'indépendance et on se dit finalement
ce sont des panneaux publicitaires
il ya les deux en fait un mois j'avais
j'achète des vêtements parce que je suis
passionné de mode déjà à la base
et puis je reçois aussi des vêtements
par les marques après clairement si les
vêtements me plaisent pas je ne présente
pas enfin je
justement je combats énormément le fait
de paille c'est un panneau publicitaire
et de de présenter que des choses qui me
plaisent des choses de qualité voilà
alors autour d un petit peu le cou aux
idées reçues à ceux qui visent à la lame
et les influences euse ce sont des
potiches qui te pardonnez moi qui
fondent et c'est finalement pour gagner
de l'argent
non du tout c'est pas voté l'attribution
il ya tout un travail derrière c'est des
heures et des heures de négociation à
qui marc désert de photos voilà je vois
sophie qui acquiesce depuis tout à
l'heure et oui c'est comme ça avec ce
qu'elle dit mais moi alors je n'ai pas
du tout le même nombre d'abonnés callies
mais c'est vrai que moi aussi je passe
énormément de temps sur instagram et
c'est presque un vrai métier c'est mon
métier
oui c'est un vrai métier sap devient par
la suite un vrai métier dans la vraie
vie
vous n'êtes pas influença vous êtes de
consultants d'un renflouement en
vraiment de commandes wii voilà c'est ça
c'est vraiment on voit d'autres photos
ici le décor c'est toujours la bordée
dijon par exemple ma la ville et les
gens pouvaient entrer ville de dijon est
ok vous surfez sur sur les tendances ou
c'est vous qui justement essayer de
créer une tendance non je surfe sur les
tendances et j'adhère complètement donc
pareil voilà ça me plairait pas je
certaines choses qui ne me plaisent pas
que je met pas en avant c'est pas des
looks que j'aime donc voila mais tout ce
que j'aime je fonce donc voilà allez
totale interactivité 0 805 383 383 bon
jour on vous écoute quel est votre
question bonjour je m'appelle vie levin
je suis pareil sur les réseaux sociaux
et je suis beaucoup d'influenceurs sur
les réseaux sociaux et ma question
aujourd'hui c'était de savoir si on peut
faire confiance aux influenceurs pour
les produits dont ils parlent aussi il
vante les qualités parce qu'ils sont
rémunérés pour mercy le divine pour
votre question on pouvait le faire au 0
805 383 383 la méfiance
même si ça rime avec la confiance c'est
parfois un petit peu compliqué on y
revient souvent là on l'a senti en le
sens de plus en plus ça fait plus ça va
plus on se dit oui les influences sur
les influences c'est ceci c'est cela
votre avis mon avis est que je présente
que des choses qui me tiennent vraiment
à coeur et qui me plaisent réellement
moi j'ai vraiment pour principe d'être
honnête avec ma communauté
et voilà après c'est vrai qu'on a des
influenceurs qui présente des produits
juste pour l'aspect financier mais voilà
ces scellés travers du mais c'est la vie
c'est la vitesse à 90 % c'est des looks
que vous présentez c'est pas simplement
un pull posé sur un cintre c'est pas une
europe
voilà comme ça dans c'est vous qui
portez à chaque fois oui oui oui c'est
important parce que je bats voilà parce
que je les aime et je vis dans le
vêtement quoi donc voila et puis surtout
je présente un look total du coup donc
les gens peuvent se projeter en disant
ah tiens j'ai un petit peu le même sweat
moi je pourrait l'associer avec tel
pantalon là etc
vous savez s'il ya des impacts derrière
parce que vous me disait fort justement
tout à l'heure parfois on me donne des
vêtements que je ne compte pas forcément
que je n'ai pas toujours en avant etc
j'en achète d'autres vous avez des
retours oui oui bah j'ai interagit
beaucoup avec ma communauté et les films
10 ha bah du coup à j'ai craqué sur la
robe que tu as présenté l'autre jour
bon alors il m'envoie des photos marie
thérèse vous me regarder avec des yeux
extraterrestes finalement le catalogue
des 3 suisses quelle ou de la redoute
d'aujourd'hui même j'étais en train de
penser à l'homme dont je vais parler à
j'ai déjà luz et justement je les ai
vraiment oui on appuie le nom mais voilà
voilà
oui oui on est en plein dedans mais on
est vraiment dans les deux extrêmes mais
avec le même la même idée c'est
maintenant je sais le voilà c'est la
mode etc
ah oui c'est c'est très bien c'est donc
plein d'initiatives ces petits jeunes
c'est bien c'est lui a bien sauf fédérer
vous suivez des influences hausse des
influenceurs de mode notamment oui bien
sûr je m'inspire beaucoup d'instagram
comme premier look aussi même pour la
vie tous les jours il ya toujours plein
de belles astuces sur instagram donc
super en tout cas l'install grammer le
youtube heures le blogueur la crau aux
réseaux sociaux
bref l'influencent y en a de l'influencé
que par l'audience finalement qui le
suit un son audience pas d' influence
exactement ça c'est vraiment important
donc attention fausse audience acheter
sur le net j insiste un peu lourdement
là dessus et parfois on peut être
désagréablement surpris en tout cas
merci